hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
in today's video we will be revisiting a
previous what i eat in a day review that
i did on stephanie joshi
from nutty foodie fitness now this video
ended up stirring up quite
the controversy and after some serious
thought and reflection
i did find that there were a few things
that i wanted to clear up about my
previous comments on stephanie's videos
to add better context and a few things
that i would like to add
now in future videos that i shoot i will
be adding a disclaimer that the videos
that i watch
cannot fully represent the full catalog
of their content so while i do do my
best and we spend about eight hours
on youtube viewing alone it is of course
impossible for me to catch every nuance
and all the context
now before we start a few other
disclaimers that the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes
only so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your
unique healthcare needs also please
as always be kind in the comments both
here
and on stephanie's channels a trigger
warning that some graphics or
discussions may be disturbing to some
viewers so of course you can always feel
free to skip this video
and do not forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you
never miss out now if you haven't
watched my previous what i in a day
video on stephanie
you can check it out right here but for
those of you who maybe haven't seen it
or for those of you who have and need a
quick little recap
here are my main takeaways from the
previous review
number one stephanie's positive attitude
towards
food so i actually really really like
stephanie's attitude towards
food we don't see stephanie using any
deity language whatsoever in her videos
she also does not seem to be overly
preoccupied with her weight
or how much she eats or what she eats or
how many calories are in what she eats
which i really like stephanie is a true
foodie at heart and i love her non-dyed
approach to food
she doesn't use any deity language or
follow any bogus diet culture rituals or
food rules
she also isn't overly preoccupied with
her weight
or what and how much she eats which i do
think
is really helpful for some people who
are struggling with dieting
or are just concerned with eating
perfectly all the time
number two she is highly in tune with
her hunger cues
stephanie really knows her hunger and
gives herself full permission to eat
when she's hungry
and as much as it takes to feel totally
satisfied even if this does look like a
lot of food to a lot of people
she continues to honor her hunger and
doesn't restrict herself
number three she shares empowering
messages towards eating
stephanie is totally aware of her unique
metabolism and appetite and
she repeatedly tells her viewers that
everyone's bodies are unique
and different and what works for her may
not work for
somebody else she also encourages her
followers to not be afraid of food
and even has a video where she eats her
followers fear foods
as a way to normalize them number four
was that there were some health
implications of concern despite
stephanie's relaxed and flexible
attitude towards food
which i totally applaud and appreciate
there were a few
health implications about stephanie's
diet that i did flag
our analysis showed that stephanie was
eating much higher amounts of saturated
fat
sodium and sugar than what would be
recommended for the average adult woman
while it's totally great and fine to eat
these foods in moderation
my only concern around stephanie's
consumption was that the frequency and
quantity
of these kinds of foods in her diet may
put her
at risk for some negative health
outcomes like
heart disease in the future now a lot of
you may ask well
if she's eating intuitively and i do
believe that she is
then why does this even matter it might
not
it honestly might not but
any time i make a comment about a meal
or a dietary pattern
on youtube it's less directed at the
unique individual
because hey i'm not stephanie's
dietitian
and i don't follow her diet every single
day but rather
i'm making statements to the general
population
based on population statistics and needs
and i do this simply to help you
understand
basic nutrition and to give you some
shortcuts
in helping you gather data on what works
for your body
if this way of eating works for
stephanie and feels good to her
amazing but research suggests that this
amount of saturated fat
sugar and salt probably wouldn't feel
balanced or result in really good health
outcomes for a lot of people
and number five my comments came off as
me making
wrongful insinuations about binge eating
and cheat days
i believe that part of being a good
professional is acknowledging when your
opinions change on a topic
or when you've been wrong in the past
rather than just getting defensive
and you know putting your guard up while
it's never
ever my intentions to tarnish any
creator's reputation
or to insinuate a creator is
purposefully engaging in deceit with
their audience
i feel very badly that that may have
happened in this case
and i'm taking full responsibility for
it by addressing these
issues today this is the kind of stuff
that keeps me up at night
i had structured the original video as
me essentially going through some of the
most plausible reasons
for stephanie's extreme fluctuations in
intake
and based on my experience the most
common cause of this extreme hunger
is previous caloric restriction i
commented that this behavior
did look like the extreme hunger that
we'd seen with other youtubers like
stephanie buttermore
and to a casual viewer all of those food
challenges
may be aligned with typical cheat day
mentality if you're a long time viewer
of my channel
you know that unfortunately we see this
a lot
in the youtube space where diet culture
and disorderly messaging
is rampant this is just so common in
what we see here across the platform
that it admittedly likely clouded my
view of her content
that is a bias that i can now see and
since making that video
i've made extra effort to be more
mindful of
constantly challenging that bias in my
content even though i never accused or
diagnosed
any of these behaviors none of this
means that stephanie has an eating
disorder
or that she is necessarily restricting
or that she's throwing up her food
none of that is necessarily truth we
don't know that
i don't know that i can see why to some
of you or to stephanie
it felt like it was implied so i want to
apologize to stephanie
and her viewers if my previous video was
insensitive
and insinuated that stephanie was
engaging in typical binge
restrict behavior my initial intention
was to point out
that to a casual viewer stephanie's
content may
look like a binge or cheat day and may
therefore be
triggering for some people who are
struggling as this was the feedback that
i received from a lot of you
when you requested the video in the
first place however i clearly did a poor
job communicating this message
and i should have really dug deeper to
fully understand stephanie's
unique case to be a better advocate for
her and for that
i do apologize funny timing during the
time that we were preparing today's
video
stephanie released a video where her and
her dad discussed
their thoughts and concerns about my
previous what i in a day review
now i can totally understand the
critique of my video and how
it may have been interpreted but again
it wasn't my intention to upset anyone
or spread any misinformation
about stephanie thankfully we did have a
kind and respectful exchange in the
comments
and i feel good that i was at least able
to apologize for some of my missteps
so stephanie like i said keep doing what
you're doing
and eating that peanut butter girl you
have my full
support with that said in today's video
i want to take a closer look at the role
of genetics and metabolism
whether or not genetic tests are legit
and
also to briefly talk about some of the
other possible reasons
one might need a lot of food first let's
take a look at the results of
stephanie's genetic tests
this was included in a video that i
regretfully missed because we generally
have a rule for our what i in a day
research
not to go back beyond a year's worth of
content just to account for any
major changes in a youtuber's lifestyle
but
let's take a peek orders equal your
genotype or genotype has the lowest
impact
my carbohydrate sensitivity is the
lowest
which would in turn explain why i
am able to consume more carbs than so my
specific genetic response
to fat intake is again on very low
you have a low sensitivity for genes
related to fat absorption putting you in
our lowest score bracket
possible for response to fat intake
the genes in this panel impact the way
your body absorbs transports and
metabolizes
dietary fat your genetic profile means
you have the lowest
effect on these factors from fat intake
meaning you are well placed to deal with
fat intake
genetically speaking when all other
factors are equal your genotype has the
lowest impact on your fat absorption
and metabolism compared to other
genotypes
okay so according to the results of the
genetic tests
uh stephanie has a low sensitivity to
carbohydrates
and saturated fat this supposedly
explains
why she's able to consume large
quantities of these types of foods
while still remaining very lean and
assumingly
metabolically healthy i will get into
the accuracy of these types of genetic
tests
later on in the video but for now let's
just break down those results
so according to her test results her low
sensitivity to carbs
means she has greater insulin
sensitivity and blood sugar control
after consuming carbs so this basically
means that
when insulin is released into the body
in response to carbohydrate intake
the body is more sensitive to the
insulin in the bloodstream
and is therefore able to more
efficiently absorb and use glucose for
energy
this allows blood sugar levels to remain
more even and reduces the likelihood of
those blood sugar spikes
on the other hand somebody with a high
sensitivity to carbs
may be less sensitive to insulin and not
as
efficient at absorbing glucose from the
bloodstream which can result in greater
spikes in blood sugar levels
as for the saturated fat the results of
this test suggest
that her genotype has the lowest impact
on the absorption
and metabolism of saturated fats
compared to other genotypes
and as we saw from my previous review
stephanie had consumed around 16 times
more saturated fat than what is
recommended for
the general population now i don't know
if this is a regular pattern for
stephanie
all i can do is go off of the
information that she shares on her
channel but assuming that eating a large
amount of saturated
fat is the norm for stephanie then the
average person would theoretically
gain more weight or experience more
health concerns from saturated fat
than what we have observed from
stephanie now it's important to note
that the report at least from what i can
see
did not really go into detail about the
intersection of this genotype
saturated fat and actual health risks
that are commonly associated with
saturated fat
namely heart disease now this is a
highly controversial topic which is why
i did a whole video on saturated fats
right here
but while the jury is still not
completely aligned with whether or not
saturated fat causes heart disease
it doesn't appear to help so until we
have more conclusive findings
we generally do recommend replacing most
of the saturated fat in your diet
with unsaturated fats or higher fiber
carbs
both of which do appear to support heart
health
stephanie seems to focus on the impact
of these findings
with regards to her lean physique but i
am way more interested
in their impact on long-term health
risks
if this genetic test is accurate which
again
i will get into soon it does state in
the very limited vague copy there that
the genes in the panel impact how fats
or carbs are metabolized and absorbed
and therefore their impact on your blood
panel but still
nothing that i can see about what really
matters
and that to me is absolute health risk i
do worry that this could be an
invitation for some people to make
potentially damaging conclusions like
go ahead and eat unlimited refined carbs
and saturated fat from a bunch of
correlations that
might not even be strong correlations to
begin with
i do see from the tiniest snippets from
the document that she
shared here that it looks like they are
giving specific recommendations like if
you have
low sensitivity to saturated fats then
you should you know cap your saturated
fats at 10 percent and if you're medium
8
etc but again i'm just not sure if the
quality of the data
warrants these types of very specific
recommendations
not to mention i'm just aware of how the
average lay person may interpret this
data
and may end up taking these
recommendations to an extreme
again before i get all hyped up i will
get into
that soon now next we have her salt
sensitivity results
let's take a look i actually have a
raised salt sensitivity i can't say that
i cook
with a lot of salt but i do consume
a lot of salty peanuts um
peanuts just chilling beside me i
will um keep an eye on that okay so
according to the results
stephanie has a higher salt sensitivity
and is encouraged to reduce her sodium
intake as a result of this
now our nutrient analysis in my last
video indicated that on average
stephanie consumed about 10 times the
daily recommendation
for sodium now for a lot of people high
intakes of sodium can cause bloating
right after a meal
and on a more serious note over time it
can also
cause increased blood pressure and heart
disease
but regardless of whether or not this
test result is valid
the recommendation to limit sodium
intake is pretty generic
universal advice that can be applied to
the majority of people
interestingly salt and saturated fats do
tend to go hand in hand in a lot of food
particularly if we're talking about
convenience foods
or restaurant foods so unless she's
eating like a lot of unsalted butter and
meat without any seasoning which
would be boring it would be pretty hard
to really get an excessive amount of
saturated fat without
also getting a good amount of salt next
was their diet recommendation and i do
want to watch this one for sure
the mediterranean diet most closely fits
my
results by the way yes i'm half spanish
the mediterranean diet
contains good fat sources in the form of
olive oil
and nuts stay nutty it says the combined
results of your genetic response to
carbohydrates and fats would suggest
that a mediterranean diet
would be a good start point for your
profile
i definitely consume a lot of nuts
but it also says as well as oily fish
quite interesting because in
my other result i found that i had a
raised
need for omega-3 which is found in foods
such as
fish mackerel salmon and sardines which
are a great source of
omega-3 up until about two years ago i
consumed no fish at all which is
outrageous given that you know i am
half spanish so i think it's pretty cool
that this test provides individualized
dietary recommendations based on the
results
which i think is the whole point of
taking a test
like this anyway or why someone like a
dietician
might use these genetic tests in their
practice
this would definitely help a user put
all of these complicated puzzle pieces
together
into a generally palatable diet but i
will say
again this does sound like pretty
generic advice that can be applied
towards the majority of people
even those without stephanie's unique
gene pool
can probably benefit from the
mediterranean diet
as it has been shown to have a variety
of health benefits
and is probably one of the most
evidence-based patterns
of eating for example research suggests
that the mediterranean diet can lead to
significant improvements in heart health
markers like cholesterol
and blood pressure another 2019 review
showed that the diet is associated with
a
lower risk of heart disease and stroke
in people with diabetes
in addition to its heart health benefits
the mediterranean diet has
also been shown to protect against type
2 diabetes
and reduce inflammation now with that
said i think that the mediterranean diet
is a great option for stephanie and
would totally
help to fill in any little nutritional
gaps that i saw on my previous review
so for example we know that despite all
of the amazing
nut butter and nuts that are happening
in our diet which is great
love the healthy fats in nuts and so
does the mediterranean diet
there are days where stephanie consumes
a lot of saturated fats like we talked
about
so the mediterranean diet may help her
pivot towards
more olive oil avocado seeds seafood
and yes keeping up those nuts now in
addition to
the healthy fats the diet also
recommends consuming
more fruits and vegetables whole grains
legumes
eggs while also limiting things like
highly processed foods
refined grains added sugars and trans
fats
so overall i think that this is a great
recommendation to help minimize the
potential risks
of a diet high in sodium and saturated
fat specifically for stephanie of course
but also for most people in
commercialized societies
now that i've talked about some of the
recommendations of the test
let's discuss whether or not those were
all totally moot points
and if genetic testing for diet and
exercise
is actually legit so nutrigenomics or
nutrigenetics
is a fairly new and exciting area of
research that looks at the genetic
variations
in an individual's dna to determine
whether
certain genes influence the way that
foods are absorbed
and metabolized genetic testing can
also provide information about whether
or not an individual is predisposed to
certain health problems because of its
potential value
a lot of registered dietitians and
doctors have now begun using genetic
testing
in their practice to supplement their
health assessments
and provide individualized
recommendations
now although the literature in this area
is still emerging and more
evidence is needed to fully support the
use of nutrigenomics
we of course do know that there is a
genetic component to body weight
and nutrient needs so for example one
study compared the dna of individuals
with smaller and larger bodies
and found that genetics did of course
play a significant factor
makes total sense and is completely
aligned
with a lot of what i talk about when i
discuss body acceptance
another study found that individuals
with a particular genotype
lost more weight by following a high
carb diet while individuals with a
different genotype
had better results following a high
protein diet again
makes sense that everyone responds
differently to different ways of eating
and this may have a genetic component
other research has looked at the genetic
variations of more than 400 000
individuals
and found that genetics did play an
important role at determining
where body fat is distributed explaining
why some people are pear-shaped and
others are more apple-shaped
as for the role of genetics and
metabolism some research
points towards the ucp-1 gene as the
genetic explanation
behind differences in metabolism and
body weight
so for example a study on 82 healthy
females
found that women with a specific
genotype variant
of the ucp1 gene had a lower
resting metabolic rate while other women
with a different genotype variant
had a higher metabolic rate variations
in other genes like the
cyp1a2 gene i feel like ob
canopy but variations in that gene
can indicate whether an individual is a
slow or fast metabolizer of caffeine
and based on this information whether or
not they should be limiting their trips
to starbucks every day
another example is the ace gene which
can indicate whether or not an
individual is at risk of high blood
pressure
in the presence of a high sodium diet so
this may help explain why some of us
hello have chronically low blood
pressure
even when we eat a really salty meal
while genetics do appear to play an
important role in an individual's
metabolism
body weight and the response to food can
genetic tests
accurately assess someone's unique
dietary needs
unfortunately because the evidence in
this area is so limited and new
most experts agree that the accuracy of
these tests
is questionable and should be taken with
a grain of salt
for one not all genetic tests on the
market are created equal
or use the same evidence to support the
recommendations
some companies may look at a wider range
of genetic markers
even if the research on these genes is
based on polygenic traits
which are basically based on multiple
allyls or
genes and is solely correlational based
correlational data tells us that two
things are linked
but it doesn't actually explain why or
how they're linked
in other words especially when we're
talking about polygenic traits
we don't really know for sure which part
of the gene
or allyl is really at work
we just know that there's a relationship
between a trait
and a series of genes it's therefore
very possible and probably quite common
that a particular gene
may play no role at all in a trait
but may just be simply present in those
with a trait
it's also not uncommon for different
companies to look at the same genes
and have completely different
interpretations of the results
and different recommendations so this
could mean that you can take
two tests from two very different
companies and receive
completely different recommendations
it's also important to note that some
genes have just been studied in more
depth than others
for example the cyp182 gene which i
talked about which looks
at an individual sensitivity to caffeine
and the
mthfr gene which is involved in the
breakdown of amino acid homocysteine
have been researched more than let's say
the slc23a1 gene
which supposedly reports on healthy
outcomes related to vitamin c status
let's just say that we desperately need
some clinical practice guidelines in
nutrigenomics
as well as some standardization on which
genes
are ethical to track with that in mind
genetic tests are
not diagnostic and should not replace
health advice from quality health
professionals
like a doctor or registered dietitian
who can help you interpret and
understand
which of these results to take more
seriously and which to maybe take with a
grain of salt
these tests should also be used in
conjunction with other health
assessments
so for example if the results of a
genetic test
indicates that you have a increased need
for vitamin d for example
as was actually the case for stephanie
it would not be advisable to just start
taking
high doses of vitamin d supplements
without maybe getting your blood work
taken
to confirm an actual vitamin deficiency
in addition a lower high sensitivity to
fat or carbohydrates
should not be a replacement for getting
regular blood work taken to check for
important health markers
like blood cholesterol and blood sugar
levels it also shouldn't give you free
range or
fried chicken sandwiches every single
day for lunch and i'm not saying that
stephanie does
any of these things i'm mainly just
talking for the general population
i also worry that these tests will be
used to replace
valid information from your body so for
example
just because your test says that you can
tolerate higher amounts of sugar
does that really mean that eating a pint
of ben and jerry's every day will feel
good for you
it might but it also might not
so i'm always weary of letting too much
of this correlational science
replace the delicate art of intuitive
eating
again i'm not saying that this is the
case for stephanie because i really do
think that she is eating
intuitively and is in tune with her body
but i'm just speaking for the general
population
now i asked my dietitian colleagues who
work in nutrigenomics
what their thoughts were on this
particular test dna fit
and they expressed some concern that
this particular test
included a lot of genes with weak
correlational research
when compared to other tests that they
prefer to use they also commented on the
fact that it draws on what a lot of them
called
sensationalized wellness culture
language which
made them a little bit weary of their
efficacy when i looked more into the
test online
there were a lot of mixed reviews with a
lot of people saying that it provided
very generalized recommendations and
that's not ideal
if you're dishing out 200 with the
expectation of receiving
personalized nutrition and fitness
information so what i'm saying
is don't think that you're getting
greater bang for your buck by choosing a
test that looks at
more traits or genes it is very likely
that a lot of those traits
are not so well studied and the
associations
may be a bit of a stretch again this is
why i recommend working with an
experienced registered dietitian
in nutrigenomics who can help to kind of
walk you through
those results genetic tests should not
be used as a replacement for other valid
or reliable health assessments
that measure nutrient deficiencies and
other important health markers
now regardless of whether or not the
genetic test here is legit
i do wholeheartedly believe that
stephanie just
has a really fast metabolism and that
genetics do play a role here
but aside from getting some genetic
tests which may or may not be accurate
what is the best way to actually
determine
a person's needs well in clinical
settings a dietitian would most
often use predictive equations to figure
out how many calories a person needs
based on their height weight age and
activity level
however as we know everyone has very
unique needs
and these predictive equations are far
from perfect
they are honestly most useful for
providing a quick estimate
for the average person but they don't
really give us
a precise figure for instance a
predictive equation
might estimate that you need 2 000
calories a day
but you might find that you just feel
better and have more energy when
consuming fewer or more calories
than what was estimated that calculation
also doesn't really take into
consideration variations within a person
and that some days you'll just need more
calories than others
due to subtle changes in activity
hormones
sleep patterns sickness etc this is why
it's so important to rely on your own
hunger and fullness cues
to guide your eating rather than
whatever an online calculator says
as your body will provide the best
indicator for your unique energy needs
and it seems like stephanie does that
which is great
if you really want to know how much a
person needs when it comes to calories
you would have to do a indirect
calorometry test
instead of looking at an individual's
height weight age and activity level
indirect calorometry estimates energy
needs by evaluating
gas exchange and measuring how much
oxygen the body requires
versus how much carbon dioxide it
produces indirect calorometry is
considered the gold
standard when it comes to measuring
energy needs however
it's very expensive and isn't available
in most clinical settings
never mind something that the average
person would ever have access to
with this in mind when we consider
stephanie's energy needs
a standard predictive equation would
estimate that she requires
approximately 2000 to 2500 calories a
day
depending on her activity level that day
but we also know that on average
stephanie consumes anywhere between like
3 000 and
7 000 calories a day sometimes even more
as we see in some of her challenge days
and it seems like she's doing it
intuitively
so we can only assume that if we were to
measure her needs using indirect
calorimetry
that they would be much higher than what
can be estimated
using a predictive equation so yes
stephanie very likely does have a higher
than average metabolism
i would assume that this has some strong
genetic origins
but it may also be modified by things
like her age
muscle mass physical activity hormones
and her microbiome in fact more and more
research is now pointing to the
importance
of the gut microbiome and its roles in
regulating energy metabolism energy
expenditure
and body weight a 2009 study evaluating
the gut microbiomes
of 154 subjects found that leaner
individuals had greater bacterial
diversity in their gut
some research also suggests that the
bacteria in the microbiome can extract
more or less calories from
food and therefore can influence
subsequent weight gain
or weight loss this means that two
people can eat the exact same amount of
food
but not actually absorb the same amount
of calories from that food
due to the variations in their gut
microbiome so this could explain why
someone like stephanie
can eat a large amount of calories and
remain lean while somebody else
might eat the same amount of food as
stephanie and gain weight and since
we're now on the topic of metabolism
i thought we could also talk about hyper
metabolism and some of the underlying
health conditions that may result
in an increased metabolism first i want
to make it very clear that i'm not
trying to diagnose or insinuate that
stephanie's fast metabolism is due to
any kind of underlying health condition
i mean
we are all born with superpowers and
being able to
very efficiently use fuel is likely one
of stephanie's
but just for interest in education's
sake i did want to discuss
some health conditions that may put an
individual
in a hyper-metabolic state
hyper-metabolism compared to just having
a generally fast metabolism like
maybe stephanie is defined as having an
elevated
resting energy expenditure of over a
hundred and ten percent
usually an individual will enter a
hypermetabolic state
when recovering from an injury a burn or
when they're struggling with cancer
pretty much any condition where your
metabolism is revved up to help heal
or recover your body as a result of
having an increased energy expenditure
hyper metabolism can lead to involuntary
weight loss
elevated heart rate and blood pressure
muscle weakness
shortness of breath excessive sweating
and
an increased need for calories while
hyper metabolism
can be a consequence of injuries and
cancer
it can also be a sign of some of these
underlying health conditions
so first is hyperthyroidism
hyperthyroidism is characterized by an
overactive thyroid gland which
overproduces thyroid hormones
causing an increase in metabolic
activity some common symptoms of
hyperthyroidism include
increased appetite frequent bowel
movements weight loss
irregular menstrual cycles hair loss and
restlessness
hyperthyroidism is often treated with
medication to stop the thyroid from
over producing thyroid hormones as well
as surgery to remove
part or all of the thyroid gland next
is graves disease so graves disease is
an
autoimmune disorder that also causes the
thyroid gland
to overproduce thyroid hormone in the
body and
is one of the most common causes of
hyperthyroidism
because of this graves disease and
hypothyroidism
share many of the same symptoms graves
disease is also eight times more common
in women
than in men and has a very strong
genetic component
treatment options for graves disease are
likewise similar to those of
hyperthyroidism
since they are so strongly linked now
third is eating disorder
recovery eating disorder recovery can
also result in a temporary state of
hyper metabolism during weight
restoration
as the body recovers from being in a
prolonged period of starvation
this means that individuals recovering
from eating disorders like
anorexia who experience hyper metabolism
require substantially more calories to
restore their bodies back to baseline
i really liked what i heard stephanie
bettermore say in a recent video of hers
to explain her
high calorie needs when going all in
where she said that after being in a
caloric deficit for so long
she really had to kind of pay back the
debt and
also pay interest at the very start of
her journey
generally an individual's metabolism
will go back to normal
about three to six months after they
fully weight restore
then there's lipodystrophy so
lipodystrophy is
not a clinical manifestation of hyper
metabolism
but is instead an abnormality in the way
that the body uses and stores
fat some individuals with lipodystrophy
lack
fat cells so they can appear very
muscular
and defined however leptin which is the
satiety hormone that tells us when we're
full
is made in fat cells so because
individuals with lipodystrophy
lack fat cells they do not create enough
leptin
this means that they can eat large
quantities of food
without actually knowing when they're
full and because their body doesn't
store fat where most of us do in our
bellies
and our bums fat can accumulate in the
liver
which can lead to fatty liver disease
insulin resistance
and high cholesterol oftentimes these
individuals
may have to actually inject leptin
hormone to help curb their hunger
and protect their liver from the
accumulation of too much fat
and finally up for discussion is
pancreatic insufficiency
so pancreatic insufficiency doesn't
really result in hypermetabolism per se
but it's still worth mentioning here so
the pancreas not only helps to regulate
blood sugar levels but it also plays a
really important role
in digestion by creating digestive
enzymes
however when the pancreas stops
producing enzymes to support digestion
the body is unable to properly digest
and absorb fats
because fats are unable to be absorbed
by the body without digestive enzymes
food kind of passes through the body
undigested
which can result in extreme weight loss
this can also lead to vitamin deficiency
especially those fat soluble vitamins
like vitamin a d e and k
in these cases it's often recommended to
take an oral pancreatic enzyme
supplement
to support digestion and prevent
malnourishment now when i brought
stephanie's case
anonymously to my dietitian practice
group everyone was like spitballing all
these potential clinical reasons
for stephanie's obviously very high
metabolism
it is definitely super interesting as a
clinician to
go into diet detective mode with
thousands of really
really highly educated and experienced
professionals
obviously none of us know stephanie's
actual case so
all of this was totally hypothetical for
the purpose of discussion
and learning but one thing that did
leave pretty much everyone a bit
perplexed was the sheer variation in
caloric intake between
her different wedding day videos this
was the confusing thing for me too
back in my first video and still here
today as i said in my last video while
it's very normal to not eat the same
amount of calories
each day research suggests that the
average daily caloric variability for
women should be
plus or minus 25 of their total actual
energy needs
normally even if a person had a genetic
predisposition to a really high
metabolism
or was managing one of the conditions
that i just spoke to which can increase
metabolism we wouldn't see a 70 to
450 percent variation from day to day
alas the cool thing about nutrition is
that while i speak here to the masses
every single person is truly unique and
stephanie's a really cool case study to
follow
and ultimately if her body is giving
these broad fluctuating messages
for consumption and this is what feels
good to her
to me it's absolutely the right way to
eat bottom line
considering how stephanie talks about
food and her body
i do want to clarify that we can only
assume
that her unique energy needs are the
result of a fast metabolism
i did try to communicate this in my last
video but i admit
that the point was lost because i was
presenting the case
disproportionately from a restrict binge
lens
that is my ear and i am owning it
obviously we really can't understand
what
stephanie's specific energy needs are
without doing a full
and accurate energy needs assessment and
we also
can't rely on genetic testing alone as
it only gives us correlational data
which may or may not be accurate again i
want to apologize to stephanie and her
viewers
if my previous video sounded like i was
insinuating that stephanie was engaging
in problematic disorder behavior but i
do want to reiterate that the main
driving point
of my previous video was that it may be
triggering for some people
who interpret stephanie's videos in this
way having said that i also want to give
credit where credit is due
and give stephanie a huge virtual high
five
in acknowledgment that her videos may
also help others normalize certain
beliefs
and practices around food ultimately
it's all up to interpretation and
different people's histories and
struggles are likely going to inform
how these things are interpreted so
stephanie keep doing you
continue to reject diet mentality
continue to be a good role model for
those struggling with fear foods
and continue to fuel your body with
whatever
feels good to you clearly it's working
because you seem
very much at peace with your body and
with food
and on that note that is all for today's
video and another reminder to please be
kind in the comments
both here and on stephanie's channel if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]